qué opinas
extremadamente de acuerdo estoy en
desacuerdo ligeramente de acuerdo estoy
de acuerdo no estoy de acuerdo Odio que
cada semana tenga que inyectarme
hormonas me enoja tanto que las personas
Islas obtengan gratis y es simplemente
natural es como tú las tienes en tu
cuerpo y yo las tengo en un cajón
adolescentes trans
saldría con una persona cisgénero en
tres dos uno
he salido con personas izantes y cada
vez especialmente porque nací como mujer
y soy no binaria si estoy saliendo con
un hombre Normalmente me vería como una
mujer vi un tic Toc sobre eso Ayer fue
como has estado con una mujer ella yo
estaba como eso está no si no puedes
verme como una persona no binaria no
puedo estar contigo con las mujeres que
son sí son más cordiales pero la gente
nos percibe como una pareja de lesbianas
y eso no es realmente lo que estoy
tratando de hacer a mi edad los chicos
se encuentran a sí mismos y a sus deseos
y es raro porque o quieren una cosa o
quieren otra y por lo general estoy
sujeta a ser fetichizada a veces vienen
a mí y me dicen Eres lo mejor de ambos
mundos y yo le digo Oye esto no es
Hannah Montana soy una chica quiero
tener mi propio pequeño momento en el
que pueda tener mi propio azul y cosas
así y tener una relación normal como el
resto de las chicas sís yo normalmente
he salido con chicas cis me han
fetichizado probablemente un par de
veces dicen Oh sí soy bisexual y
entonces me ven como una chica o algo
así y es tan extraño pero hace poco salí
con alguien que no existe y se
identifican como no binarios Y esa
relación me enseñó mucho porque siento
que realmente me vieron por lo que soy y
fueron las personas más conscientes solo
he estado con una persona Asís y era una
chica y siento que las chicas son mucho
más comprensivas pero todavía estoy
abierto a una persona Asís realmente
depende de la persona no busco una
persona trans solo Busca una buena
persona
debería poder hacer la transición médica
antes de la edad adulta en tres dos uno
muchos de nosotros nos hemos dado cuenta
de que esto es lo mejor para nosotros
como niños y se trata de nuestra salud
mental y bienestar pero dicho eso creo
que también es importante que esto sea
lo que realmente quieres porque va a ser
una decisión que cambiará tu vida y
detrás de eso debe haber mucha
evaluación y muchas afirmaciones es
justo lo que iba a decir depende de
donde estés debes estar en un punto
específico y asegurarte de estar listo
pero sí creo que ayudaría a muchos
chicos trans con su salud mental solo el
hecho de poder hacer la transición antes
de los 18 Yo muero por ponerme hormonas
y estoy de acuerdo en que los chicos
deberían poder recibir hormonas y
someterse a la trh pero también hay una
pequeña parte de mí que dice y si
terminan cambiando de opinión
cuando tenía 13 años pensé que era un
hombre trans y luego dije no y luego
dije espera entonces para mí fue solo
mucho cuestionamiento y pasar por
diferentes identidades hasta que
encontré lo que se sentía bien y en el
punto en el que estoy ahora ni siquiera
sé si quiero someterme a la trh Entonces
si hubiera continuado con eso a los 13
pues no creo que me hubiera arrepentido
pero me alegro de haber internalizado
mucho de eso y haberlo procesado creo
que mientras eduquemos a los niños sobre
el riesgo de hacer la transición muy
jóvenes la transición médica y se les
eduque sobre el proceso Creo que
deberían poder elegir si quieren hacerlo
no
mis profesores aceptan mis pronombres en
tres dos uno
[Música]
fui a UCI por un trimestre y fueron muy
comprensivos casi no hicieron preguntas
pero en la escuela secundaria así fue
una lucha porque mi nombre era un nombre
diferente en la lista y luego tendría
que explicarlo en especial mi profesora
de español quien tenía creencias
católicas entonces me apartaba a un lado
y me hacía preguntas y fue muy dulce de
su parte tratar de entender pero también
fue difícil para ellos recordarlo en
clase y cosas así
sinceramente estoy muy agradecida de que
intentaran encontrar una manera de hacer
que las personas trans se sintieran un
poco más cómodas en la escuela por
ejemplo estoy tomando una clase de
ballet en pilates Y pensé que iba a ser
Oh pero naciste hombre así que tienes
que hacer cosas de representación
masculina a las que de verdad les tenía
miedo pero estoy tan contenta de que
realmente lo estén aceptando yo estoy
yendo la use berly y allí se equivocan
conmigo siempre me presento un profesor
y le digo Por cierto uso los
soy no binaria respete mis pronombres y
en dos ocasiones en el salón de clases
volvieron a usar el pronombre ella y
otros compañeros de clase también me
confunden siempre de género y de verdad
puede volverse exhaustivo así que solo
dejó de intentarlo porque es agotador
tener que darse cuenta de que nadie te
ve como no binario por tener cualidades
femeninas en ti he salido del closet más
de una vez en tres dos uno
he salido varias veces no solo por mi
experiencia trans sino también por mi
sexualidad porque salí como pansexual
luego salí como bisexual y luego salí
como no binario antes de salir como
trans estaba como Oh Dios mío Cuántos
cuándo voy a aceptarlo sí Igual yo creo
que pasé por cuatro o cinco sexualidades
diferentes hasta que dije espera y luego
tengo ganas de presentarme como
andrógino es una lucha diaria el tener
que decir Oye sé que me veo así pero
esto es lo que soy así es como me siento
puedes respetarlo o no la verdad siento
que será así para siempre siento que
tengo que salir todos los días con las
personas nuevas que voy conociendo
constantemente debo decir o sí mi nombre
es Mandy soy no binaria uso los
pronombres eyeles respetalos por favor
yo debo decírselo a la gente Todos los
días cualquiera que conozca quiero que
la gente sepa de inmediato que soy trans
porque no quiero mencionarlo más tarde y
que un problema para ellos siento que
solo salí una vez porque después de la
primera vez lo hice digamos visible y no
quería hablar de eso no quería volver a
salir y yo afortunadamente tuve personas
muy solidarias en mi vida con las que
podría haber vuelto a hablar pero me
sentí mucho más cómodo simple mente
viviendo mi vida y teniendo personas que
solo aceptarán lo que estoy haciendo sin
tener que volver a salir
las personas sin género no entienden mis
luchas
en 3 2 1
en mi caso las personas intentan mucho
empatizar y la verdad aprecio eso pero
en lo personal creo que las personas Sí
están por hecho su Euforia de género se
arreglan por la mañana y se miran a sí
mismos y no sienten angustia cuando yo
me levanto me arreglo y me miro
físicamente Estoy angustiada creo que no
me veo como la persona que estaba
soñando que era entienden he conocido a
personas que eran cis Irán transfóbicas
conmigo y luego después de unos años
comienzan a hacer la transición y dicen
Oh ahora lo entiendo y no fue hasta que
pasaron por eso que realmente sintieron
el dolor y lo pudieron entender muy bien
trato de pensar en todo el espectro de
personas cis que se identifican como
mujeres pero por alguna razón sus
cuerpos se presentan más masculinos
siento que pueden tener ese tipo de
punto de vista que puede ayudarlas a
simpatizar
y empatizar más contigo se trata del
espectro y de cómo hay tantos matices
la vida Sería más fácil si no fuera
trans en tres dos uno
lo mío es que ella soy una persona de
color si no fuera no binario sería mujer
así que la vida igual no Sería fácil
para mí y siento que no sería lo mismo
pero no sería necesariamente más fácil
Yo estoy de acuerdo con lo que dices
sobre ser una persona de color y cerquir
pero he pasado por mucha basura horrible
y si creo que mi vida Sería más fácil si
fuera así es decir una parte definitoria
de lo que soy es definitivamente ser
trans pero todos los días me pregunto
Qué pasaría si hubiera nacido como una
mujer sí odio todavía tener que pensarlo
tanto me pregunto cómo sería la vida si
fuera Asís o si desearía hacersis sé que
no estaría donde estoy y no conocería
casi nadie en mi vida si no fuera trans
y si no hubiera pasado por las luchas
por las que pasé saben Odio que cada
semana tengan que inyectarme hormonas me
enoja tanto que las personas Islas
obtengan gratis y es simplemente
y Hay momentos en los que mi seguro está
siendo molesto y no puedo obtener mis
hormonas es muy molesto yo las tengo en
un cajón Sí es muy muy difícil y me
duele pero sé que no sería quien soy
sino fuera una persona trans sí Y ahora
que lo pienso solo la idea de
despertarme y no tener disforia por algo
y no probarme 15 camisetas distintas
porque mi pecho No se ve lo
suficientemente plano solo cosas así me
harían la vida más fácil pero no
conocería a las personas que tengo en mi
vida y agradezco por ellos y eso sería
todo pueden darse un gran aplauso
[Aplausos]
ver más quieres estar en un video
suscríbete a nuestras novedades de
casting y miriam.com slashcasting
suscríbete síguenos en @yubidia slash@gv
[Música]
estoy orgullosa de ser Ciudadana de mi
país
orgullosa de ser estadounidense